[Music]
recently walmart and other companies
have been offering
phones free apps and other incentives to
encourage americans to return to work
but many workers are waiting for hourly
jobs that
pay enough for them to actually make a
decent living it turns out employers
can't seem to wrap their heads around
that
now we could do a long detailed
explanation of labor relations to help
corporations understand where people are
coming from
we could or we could do this
[Applause]
no health insurance or groceries
you can't afford to travel anywhere
if you break a leg god forbid
you gotta start a gofundme how does it
feel
when there's no living wage and nothing
is free
and when you get to work you don't get
breaks to be
living wage in america
no benefits no paid vacation
living wage in america
no maternity leave for your vocation
living wage in america
[Music]
you might not be living in a third world
country but we get closer every day
check out these sad hourly rates
like kentucky kentucky detroit city
detroit city
idaho idaho pittsburgh pa
pittsburgh p.a north dakota north dakota
indiana
indiana georgia georgia
texas and utah living wage in
america
it don't exist that's an abomination
living wage in america
we need a new minimum wage for the whole
nation
living wage in america
it would feel so good
you